bon sang huit mois se sont déjà écoulés
mais qu'est ce que ça fait du bien de
reparler de star wars
ça me rappelle de nombreux souvenirs je
me sens prêt à vous refaire des théories
sur l'univers ça m'avait beaucoup manqué
et pour ce faire j'ai décidé aujourd'hui
de vous parler du rôle de kyle lorraine
et des chevaliers de rennes dans star
wars 9
mais avant ça j'aimerais vous parler
d'un partenariat car cette vidéo est en
partenariat avec altedia concernant
leurs comics star wars
ils m'ont demandé de vous dire ce que
j'ai pensé de leur livre et je ne vais
rien vous cacher j'ai été étonné de la
qualité des livres nous ne sommes pas
face à de simples magazine mais de
véritables livres d'une grande qualité
pour parler de son contenu ses livres
retrace la célèbre histoire de star wars
que nous connaissons les dessins sont
très beaux et sont faits par de vrais
créateurs de comics le seul bémol pour
moi et que je pensais découvrir plus de
choses ces livres sont plus des objets
de collection pour les véritables fans
de star wars que deux sources à
exclusivité fin du mois dans ce que j'ai
eu en tout cas pour les intéressés un
lien est disponible dans la description
pour obtenir ses livres j'ai également
un code promotionnel qui s'affiche à
l'écran et qui va vous permettre
d'obtenir un terme au star wars mais
faites attention car ce code
promotionnel n'est disponible que
jusqu'au 17 mars
allez bref passons maintenant à la vidéo
[Musique]
alors il est vrai il ya huit mois je
vous avais parlé de tout ce que nous
savions sur star wars 9 de nombreux leak
qui sont assez fondée mais aujourd'hui
nous allons ignorer tout ça en
visionnant star wars 8 de nouvelles
idées me sont apparues et j'ai une
nouvelle analyse à vous proposer
commençons par les chevaliers de rennes
d'autres grands vidéastes ont déjà émis
de très bonnes choses à leur sujet comme
ça une molle par exemple mais je vais
essayer de vous apporter ma touche
personnelle avec cette vidéo 100%
subjective nous ne savons rien sur les
chevaliers de rennes à part qu'ils
étaient très certainement des anciens
élèves de luke skywalker et qu'ils ont
participé à la destruction de son temple
jedi
il travaille également pour snoeck ait
été le cas il aurait non un peu comme
leur leader d'où le fait qu'il soit le
maître des chevaliers de rennes
d'ailleurs et je pense que vous le savez
déjà depuis un moment ryan johnson a
déclaré qu'il n'avait pas mis les
chevaliers de rennes dans star wars 8
qui était déjà très complet qu'il aurait
pu les remplacer par la garde
prétorienne mais que cela aurait gâché
leur apparition car a déjà il devrait
mourir et qu'en plus ils sont liés à
kayes lorraine donc ils ne peuvent pas
mourir sans affecter leur chef
succinctement voici ce que nous savons
sur les chevaliers de rennes mais
pourtant il y a des choses à dire
tout d'abord je pense que vous serez
d'accord avec moi il est d'une quasi
évidence que les chevaliers de rennes
apparaîtront dans star wars 9
les réalisateurs n'ont plus le choix
tout simplement car ils ont été
introduits dans la saga et montrer c'est
jj abrams qui s'occupait de star wars 7
et c'est donc lui qui les a introduits
étant donné qu'il saute de star wars 9
il possède une certaine responsabilité
par rapport à leur venue d'ailleurs
ryan johnson pensait à la base d
utiliser ceci prouve bien qu'ils n'ont
pas été oubliés et qu'ils ont toujours
leur importance surtout vu la mention de
l'udc par rapport à la poignée d'élèves
qui se serait rebellé au côté de cai
lorraine si il parlait bien des futurs
chevaliers de rennes cela prouve encore
qu'il ne sont pas totalement mis de côté
mais bref ce n'est que mon propre point
de vue
en parlant de ryan johnson j'aimerais
que nous revenions justement sur ces
déclarations
car sans le savoir ce dernier a révélé
de lure deux informations sur le club
rennes soyons logiques premièrement il
dit que star wars 8 est déjà très
complet et qu'il n'y avait littéralement
pas de place pour un autre élément
alors c'est tout bête vous allez trouver
et mais ryan johnson confirme bien en
disant ceci que les chevaliers de rennes
sont des personnages importants de la
saga
ils ne voulaient d'ailleurs pas les
gâcher cela veut dire qu'ils ont
forcément un assez gros impact sur la
saga de quoi rassurer ceux qui attendent
leur présence dans le neuf mais le plus
croustillant et le coeur de sa
déclaration
ryan avait affirmé que j'imagine que
j'aurais pu les utiliser à la place de
la garde prétorienne celle de snacks
mais cela aura été du gaspillage car je
savais que les gars d'aller mourir vite
et 6 kg avait un lien quelconque avec
eux cela aurait rajouté une complication
qui n'aurait pas aidé la scène que pour
vous nous analysé dans ceux ci
ryan affirme qu'il pouvait remplacer la
garde prétorienne par les chevaliers de
rennes ce que nous pouvons comprendre
ici c'est que les chevaliers de rennes
possède une puissance égale à la gare de
snacks en termes de combat très
certainement c'est du moins ce que moi
je ressens surtout par rapport à la
raison qui la porte par la suite si cai
lorraine avait un lien avec eux cela
aurait rajouté une complication ils
n'ont donc pas été amenés seulement pour
une complication sentimentale la seule
chose qui pourrait me faire douter c'est
le je savais que les gars d'aller mourir
vite
ceci voudrait dire que ryan ne voulait
pas que les chevaliers meurt rapidement
peut-être car elles sont un peu plus
puissante la garde prétorienne ou que du
moins ils sont plus importants que
scénaristiquement parlant
a vous de me dire ce que vous aviez
pensé sa déclaration dans les
commentaires je sais que je me prends
tardivement j'en suis vraiment désolé
bien mais que vont-ils devenir dans star
wars 9
à quoi vont ils servir pour cela il faut
que nous parlions de kayes lorraine le
nouveau suprême leader l'absence des
chevaliers de rennes dans la saga
pourrait être justifiée pour moi par la
manipulation de snow knock était très
intéressé par cas et lorraine
il avait décelé en lui une très grande
puissance et depuis sa rébellion face à
luke cage lorraine a été isolé par
snoeck pour qu'il en prenne le contrôle
total
ce serait pour moi la raison logique de
l'absence des chevaliers qui sont
d'ailleurs des amis entre guillemets et
des compagnons d'armes de ben
effectivement les chevaliers de rennes
travaillent pour snow que mais de façon
assez libre ils n'ont pas à rester
auprès de snacks et justement je pense
qu'il les a envoyés aux quatre coins de
la galaxie pour mieux maîtriser ben
suite à la mort de ce look
il est évident que cai lorraine va
rappeler ses ex compagnons d'armes pour
former sa pseudo garde personnelle avec
les chevaliers de rennes d'où la
comparaison avec la garde prétorienne de
ryan johnson l'utilisation de ces
personnages va pour moi être énormément
liés à ce que va devenir benso l'oqai
lorraine devient de plus en plus sombre
ce dernier nous a prouvé qu'il était un
manipulateur hors pair dans star wars 8
il devient égocentrique il prend la
place de son ancien maître souhaite
bâtir un nouveau monde
alors non non non je ne dirais pas que
kay lorraine est un site malgré qu'il
réunit toutes les qualités pour ce
dernier bien que la colère et la haine
le gagne souhaite mettre fin aux jedi
mai
également au site key lorraine possède
toujours une part de bonté en lui le
problème étant que ben a vaincu snoeck
et s'il n'est pas devenu un véritable
site c'est parce que justement il a été
formé par snow qu'un personnage qui
n'est pas un adepte du côté obscur et
maîtrisant surtout le pouvoir politique
preuves à l'appui qu'il aurait n'a
réussi à le berner et prendre sa place
néanmoins le fait d'avoir pris la place
du supprime leader a réveillé un côté
encore plus sombre que nous n'avions
jamais vu chez cailler lorraine il ne
pourra jamais devenir un site car ces
derniers n'existe plus mais il va se
rapprocher le plus possible
et justement si nous lions se fier aux
chevaliers de rennes un gouffre entre
eux et kyle lorraine s'est formée et va
encore plus s'élargir
ryan nous interpréter un côté
sentimental existe entre kyle lorraine
et ses chevaliers
mais suite à l' isolement créé par snk
et sa formation dans le côté obscur de
la force
puis sa montée au pouvoir cai lorraine
n'est plus le même que lorsqu'il a trahi
lui qu il a changé voix important de
nouveaux acteurs seront présents dans
star wars neuf comme matt smith ou
encore dominic monaghan et ce ne sont
pas les seuls
ces acteurs pourraient jouer les
chevaliers de rennes accompagnant caille
lorraine pour justement donner un
véritable rôle au personnage et non une
simple garde du suprême leader les
chevaliers de rennes sont à la base les
compagnons de calais lorraine et non du
suprême leader élu comme le maître des
chevaliers de rennes ce dernier était
pour eux un symbole un leader mais
voyant leur ex compagnon devenir de plus
en plus sombre de plus en plus
égocentrique les rennes pourrait trahir
ben et ne plus vouloir le servir
laissons donc ben seul avec ses pensées
et sa conscience pour moi un star wars 9
sera en quelque sorte le film de la
rédemption de ben solo après tout mais
madame driver laissé sous-entendre un
possible retour en arrière ben pourrait
lâcher prise ou bien si ce n'est pas le
cas devra mourir seul pour conclure
j'aimerais que nous allions sur un
terrain un peu plus philosophique le
point de vue de la force a totalement
changé dans l'époque de la nouvelle
trilogie
les jedi et les sith n'existe plus
vraiment du moins le compte
key lorraine ou plutôt ben solo ne
mourra pas d'après moi déjà dans star
wars 8 il était déchirée entre deux
côtés et sa relation avec rennes nous a
prouvé qu'il peut encore éprouver des
sentiments amicaux ray possède des
moyens pour faire chavirer key lorraine
les souvenirs de son passé avec les
chevaliers de rennes ses ex compagnons
d'armes peuvent faire chavirer caille
lorraine la future mort de leia dans
star wars 9
cette dernière est obligé de
malheureusement nous quitter dans le
film peut faire chavirer key lorraine et
enfin à vous de me dire d'ailleurs si
vous aimeriez une vidéo entièrement
dédié à lui dans star wars 9 mai le
retour de luke skywalker qui va hanter
les jeunes suprême leader peut faire
chavirer caille lorraine j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura plu
je suis vraiment content d'avoir pu
repérer star wars bon sens que ça
m'avait manqué mais vraiment si c'est
également le cas pour vous n'hésitez pas
à laisser votre plus gros pouce bleu
pour le retour des théories sur star
wars
car ce n'est pas la dernière fois que
nous avons parlé de la saga pensez
également activer la cloche c'est
vraiment très important pour moi vous
pouvez également vous abonner partager
la vidéo me suivre sur twitter me
soutenir via utile et pour ceux qui sont
intéressés par les comics star wars 2
chez altaï à n'oubliez pas le code
promotionnel promo argot rock qui n'est
disponible que jusqu'au 17 mars
enfin bref c'était targue rock et que le
lay honneur soit avec vous
[Musique]